hello everybody and welcome back to the
channel I know this is supposed to be a
systems Design Channel but here is a
piece of Life advice that is not systems
design related for a few more days IHOP
is doing five dollar unlimited Pancakes
on an unrelated note for some reason
I've been having really bad shits lately
but anyways let's go ahead and get into
the video because today we're talking
about stream processing Frameworks
alrighty so like I mentioned today we're
going to be discussing stream processing
Frameworks so basically a lot of context
for this video comes from the last video
in which we discussed data joins in
streams and what that really requires
intuitively is that in our consumer of
multiple streams we basically need to be
caching a lot of the results of the
events that we've seen so far so if you
can see here for example if we wanted to
join two streams one for searches from a
user ID and one for clicks on a user ID
we would need to effectively make sure
to cache all of the things that we've
seen so far place them in some sort of
cache map and then put them in a hash
join so that we could join those events
and then put them into some sync queue
but of course that does beg the question
how can we make sure that all of our
consumers are fault tolerant because
when you store things in memory that
consumer can go down and especially when
we've got a lot of consumers this can be
a problem fault tolerance is not easy
and we will discuss why so stream
processing Frameworks that is hopefully
going to allow us to be fault tolerant
and in addition to that even more
importantly ideally make sure that every
single event that we see only affects
the state of each consumer once this
isn't exactly the same as exactly one's
message delivery guarantees because in
theory a message can and will be
replayed right it's not guaranteed that
you know if there's another system
outside of your group of consumers that
they might not be affected multiple
times but within your consumers within
what's managed by your stream processing
framework each message should only
affect your state once so what are some
actual examples of stream processing
Frameworks well we've got flank we've
got spark streaming we've got tez we've
got storm I personally am most familiar
with Flink just through looking into it
the most so I'm going to talk about that
a lot but I can say with certainty at
least between flank and something like
spark streaming the main difference is
that spark streaming uses micro batches
where from an event queue we might pull
five or ten elements at a time whereas
flank is Real Time effectively meaning
that it handles events as they come in
which in theory should lower the latency
of your processing time of each message
which is good another thing about flank
and Spark streaming at least are that
they are declarative meaning that as
opposed to having to specify every
single detail of computation if you have
a partition setup which you likely
probably will you can simply kind of
specify the target of your output format
you know what you're looking for in your
data what type of joins you want to do a
little bit but generally speaking you've
got some sort of job manager and it's
going to handle a lot of the actual
logic under the hood for you which is
very very nice the last thing is that a
lot of people do confuse stream
processing Frameworks with the message
Brokers themselves they are not the same
when I say stream processing Frameworks
generally speaking I am referring it to
the stream consumers
so let's ask ourselves why is it that
fall tolerance is hard because the
low-hanging fruit of fault tolerance is
basically you know just having a bunch
of replicas of a consumer and you know
that's easy enough and and every single
time that a consumer went down we could
just restore one of the replicas and
place that in our Flink setup instead
but uh it's actually not so easy and I
will explain why right now so let's
imagine that we've got the following
setup right we've got one producer node
which is outputting to two different
cues then in addition to that we've got
two consumers of those cues and each of
those consumers is going to in turn be
publishing to sync cues which go to our
last consumer consumer three
so let's imagine now that we've got
consumer two over here and the first
thing that it's going to do is you know
receive a message from the input queue
push a message to its sync queue so
that's step one step two is that
consumer two goes down so it's going to
die and it's going to go down before it
actually has the chance to register with
this guy over here that it processed the
message successfully so now this queue
is not going to know that it is no way
to know that the message over here has
actually been put into this queue over
here and C3 will be able to see it so
the issue with that is that when C4
comes up and replaces C2 C4 is going to
read from this queue it's going to get
that message
and it yet again is going to place it in
this queue and now that message is
duplicated C3 is going to see it twice
so how is it within flank that we can
actually guarantee that every single
message is going to be processed not
just at least once but also only once
well the main answer is that we are
going to do this via checkpointing so
typically what Flink will do is we've
got all this state in a bunch of our
different consumers and occasionally
we're going to checkpoint it right over
here into S3 that way if a single node
goes down of our consumers what we can
actually do is go ahead and restore our
state from our checkpoint because the
checkpoint is going to contain the state
from all of our consumers and then from
there we can actually replay the
messages in our cues the reason we could
do that is because we require replayable
cues now if you remember from two videos
ago generally speaking that's going to
be log based message Brokers things like
Kafka where effectively all of the
events stay on disk and are not removed
from the queue after they are read but
instead are persistent so how do we
actually go ahead and take these
checkpoints well like I mentioned flank
under the hood has some sort of job
manager right in that job manager you
don't really have to worry about it too
much it's just one of your nodes
probably attached to a zookeeper
instance somehow just to keep track of
which you know consumers are running
which are up which are down same for all
of your Kafka cues or anything like that
and so let's imagine we have a similar
setup to the previous example that I
just mentioned where effectively you
know we've got a producer publishing to
two consumers and then those consumers
themselves are publishing to a third
consumer and we kind of have a join
there of two cues so what the job
manager will actually do is the
following as you can see we've got this
B right here and what that's called is a
barrier message so here's how the
barrier message is actually going to
work it is going to make its way through
the queue
get over here to the end and then once
any single node receives a barrier
message for example C1 is going to see
that b it is then going to checkpoint
its state
and place it in S3 simple enough right
same thing for C2 eventually the B is
going to come here checkpoint it's state
place it in S3 now the really really
cool thing about barrier messages is
that they allow us to make sure that all
of our snapshots are causally consistent
the reason being that a node for example
such as this one right here C3 is only
going to take its snapshot once it
receives a barrier message from all of
its input cues so it's not enough if we
only see this guy right here up top we
have to make sure that we actually see
every single barrier message from all of
the input cues and what that allows us
to do is it basically gives us some
amount of state or rather some point in
time where all of the messages that have
been processed are the same on every
single node in our system right anything
else that could have been additionally
processed we know is not going to be a
part of our checkpoint and I'll make
sure to kind of Link the semantic
reasoning for this below because I don't
really want to do a full proof in like a
10 minute video but the gist is that we
have actually
we effectively get a consistent state of
our data where we know that when we
resume from our snapshot every single
event that has been played has been
played in all of our consumers and
similarly every event that has not been
played has been played in none of our
consumers and so as a result of that we
can actually rely on our snapshots a
node goes down we back up from our
snapshot we replay as expected because
keep in mind these Kafka cues actually
will keep the state
of every consumer
so they remember exactly where each
consumer was during this snapshot
because you know we're just going to
read right after the barrier node so
wherever the barrier node was from one
message on right there that's where
we're resuming from the snapshot which
is great
and so
as a result of that Flink is able to not
only ensure fault tolerance but let's
say C3 went down
as opposed to having to replay every
single message that was in both of these
cues in order to restore its state
instead we can just restore from a
snapshot
and then basically go ahead and only
have to replay a few of those messages
hopefully this generally makes sense so
what's the conclusion of a technology
like Flink well first of all their
snapshots are super lightweight the
reasoning being that uh you're not
actually doing any locking or directly
writing to the objects or the state and
memory but flank will actually make
copies of the state specifically so that
you don't have to lock when you receive
barriers which is really great for
keeping things lightweight and
relatively quick once the snapshot is
taken then all of that duplicate State
can be garbage collected additionally
this is going to allow us to ensure that
all messages affect State on our
consumers exactly once their great
guarantees about the snapshots which
ensure fault tolerance but also more
importantly ensure that we don't have to
replay every single message of all time
in the event of a node crash there could
literally be hundreds of thousands if
not millions of messages and if a node
went down and we had to replay a million
message our entire stream processing
setup would be down for probably days so
as a result it's extremely important
that we can snapshot restore from that
snapshot and then only have to replay a
few messages from there to get back to
where we want to be so again guys this
is a super useful technology for stream
processing and it's very important that
if you come up on a systems design
interview question where it actually has
to do with stream processing and
somebody asks you how you're going to
make sure that your consumers are fault
tolerant you want to know how something
like Flink might work because you never
know when someone might ask you to
redesign something similar anyways guys
have a good day and I will see you for
the next one